Today, we are going to explore some Japanese history and tradition.
We're going to make Japanese sweets, dress in a traditional kimono...
...and be taken through the steps of a Japanese tea ceremony.
Kimono is basically made of just one fabric.
There's a very important art to dressing in the kimono,...
...so they're going to teach us how to get dressed.
All right, make it nice and snug.
Now that we're fully dressed in our kimono,...
...it's time to head up for the tea ceremony.
Welcome to Nagoya.
Tea ceremonies started in the 1600s.
It's the combination of Shintoism and also the Zen,...
...which is related to harmony and transience.
Wow, that's beautiful.
There are plenty of opportunities to take photos throughout the place...
...and even dress up as a samurai warrior.
Now it's time to learn how to make some Japanese sweets.
I think the thing I like most about the Japanese way of doing things...
...is simplicity can equal such beauty.
How's that?
Thank you!